et maintenant way scilly au spécial
chambre à part troisième extrait et
deuxième star anti-langue de bois les
tout ce que j'aime moi les 90 honte à
toi bichette m'appelle pas michel louis
aliot bonsoir je t'ai vu dans le nouveau
film de pince pas nouveau c'est le
premier c'est jacky gautier 31 et doux
et très doué quand tu nous en parle
comment tu fais marie tu viens que
dutronc vous brancher sur un sur un
couple composé de michel blanc et de
flat six barres d'or c'est très bien
aussi bon train
qu'est-ce qui se passe eh ben on rentre
dans leur vie ont fait irruption dans la
vie on fout le bordel mais en fait ça le
post 1 tu mettais du coup de balai les
pique-assiettes professionnel très
attention